60 milliards c'est le nombre de mètres
carrés de tissus jetés chaque année lors
de la découpe industriel de nos
vêtements
ce qui représente environ 15% de la
production mondiale
et tout ça c'est sans parler des déchets
post consommation parce que c'est vrai
on parle de plus en plus dans les médias
de tous nos vêtements que l'on jette
dans les poubelles ou dans les bornes de
tri mais on parle très peu de ce qui se
passe lors de la fabrication
avant même que le vêtement ne soit
cousue ni porter mais alors qu'est ce
qui se passe dans cette fabrication
il ya une douzaine d'années de ça j'ai
développé une certaine addiction à la
couture j'avais cruellement envie
d'apprendre à fabriquer moi même mes
vêtements
alors je me suis rapidement orientée
vers une filière pro en enchaînant un
bep un bac pro et un bts pour apprendre
les métiers de la mode alors tout de
suite quand on évoque métiers de la mode
c'est waou tu veux devenir styliste
veux tu dois être tellement balèze un
dessin non moi le destin c'était
vraiment pas mon truc je le faisais pas
ce qu'il fallait le faire mais je
trouvais ça assez vite comme pratique en
fait moi ce que je vais faire si tu de
créer des choses avec mes mains de créer
des volumes avec du tissu et c'est comme
ça que j'arrivais à transmettre ce que
j'avais dans la tête elle plus drôle
dans tout ça c'est que souvent
j'arrivais à dessiner quelque chose de
potable
une fois que le vêtement était déjà
découpé cousu blier angers bref ça
servait plus à grand chose
alors mes profs me disais bon alors toi
clairement tu feras jamais une bonne
stylisme mais par contre un bon profil
de technicienne du coup tu pourras te
fermes aux délices hockey balle hors du
coup j'ai suivi leurs conseils et choyés
dans cette direction le modélisme pour
ceux qui ne savent pas c'est le fait de
transformer une idée de d un dessin 2d
en un volume 3d en créant des patrons et
les patrons ce sont ses formes qui sont
souvent en papier que l'on pose sur le
tissu pour découper les éléments du
vêtement
il faut savoir que le modélisme c'est un
métier qui est
très très minutieux est assez rigide
puisqu'à chaque fois que l'on développe
un nouveau prototype de vêtements il
faut suivre des règles et il faut
toujours partir de bases qui sont
communes à toute l'industrie alors au
fur et à mesure j'ai un peu alimenté
cette rigueur de modélisme qui m'avait
été enseignées et je suis petit à petit
rentrer dans le moule façonné par
l'enseignement pour l'industrie textile
et j'ai même choisi de mon plein gré de
me spécialiser dans les systèmes
d'industrialisation de la production
textile
alors autant vous dire que là je disait
clairement à dieu à toutes sortes de
créativité et un beau jour j'ai trouvé
un de job dans l'industrie
ma mission c'était de conseiller des
marques de prêt à porter de luxe dans
l'utilisation de logiciels de cfao donc
conception assistée par ordinateur pour
le développement des collections de
vêtements
alors là j'apprends de nouvelles règles
de nouvelles méthodes de travail de
nouveaux standards industriels
bon ben j'écoute j'observe et j'intègre
tout ça progressivement et au bout de
quelques mois
toute cette absorption massive de
nouvelles règles génère en moi quelques
questionnements par ci par là mais bon
après tout je dis rien les règles sont
les règles
en fait l'industrie textile me fascine
mais j'ai la sensation que quelque chose
ne tourner pas rond
alors je fais pas mal de recherches je
lis sur l'actualité textile je me
renseigne et les mots qui en ressortent
sont des localisations sur production
exploitation surconsommation auditions
et toutes ses brillantes activités se
raccroche à une tendance commune la fast
fashion
alors évidemment je cautionne pas mais
que je le veuille ou non avec le métier
que je fais je contribue à tout ce
système
alors à défaut de tout plaquer j'entame
une petite révolte personnelle et je me
lance ce défi de tenir 365 jours sans
acheter un seul vêtement neuf dans le
but de boycotter toutes les enseignes
textiles avec lesquels je travaille au
quotidien
qui font la face à chalon c'est donc
pendant sept années que je développe une
trentaine de vêtements et c'est aussi
pour moi l'occasion d'apprendre à
customiser mes vêtements à obstacles et
des anciens vêtements que je ne m'étais
pu mais aussi à consommer le textile de
manière plus réfléchie
pourtant un détail m'a particulièrement
dérangé pendant cette année c'est la
quantité de tissu que je n'étais lorsque
je découpais mes vêtements dans nos
salons par exemple cette robe que j'ai
réalisé pendant cette année donc assez
simple avec un dos un devant et une
ceinture sur 1 m de tissu nécessaires à
la fabrication de cette robe seuls 78 %
du tissu étaient utilisées et les 22
autres les 22 % restants des poubelles
je savais pas quoi en faire et là on
parle bien d'une salle rabat alors
imaginez à l'échelle d'une production de
10000 robe parce que ça représenterait
vous comprenez peut-être un peu mieux
maintenant d'où viennent ces 60
milliards de mètres carrés de tissus
jetés chaque année et en fait c'est
assez fou parce que tout ça je le savais
mais en fait on m'a tellement rabâché
pendant mes années d'école que si
j'arrivais à créer des vêtements qui
utilisaient 80 % du tissu bas c'était
déjà très bien que je me suis jamais
posé de questions sur les 15 20 %
restants en fait c'était juste des
chiffres
une des raisons aussi à ça c'est que
jamais jamais eu l'occasion par moi-même
de découper 30 vêtements d'affilée et de
me rendre compte ce que ça pouvait
représenter à l'échelle d'une production
et à ce moment là je me rends compte
aussi que 15 % ça veut dire 15 % de
l'énergie et l'argent déboursé dans la
culture des fibres la récolte le tissage
la tenture le transport tout ça c'était
dépensés pour rien sinon pollués et
toutes ces chutes finissent en asie loin
d'ici dans les décharges sans jamais
être recyclé c'est un vrai désastre
écologique
alors évidemment les entreprises ont
recours à des logiciels qui leur
permettent de calculer la meilleure
manière de placer les patrons sur le
tissu et gagne quelques petit
pourcentage de matière mais qu'on se le
dise on est bel est bien loin du miracle
tout simplement parce que
géométriquement parlant et je pense que
je vous apprendrai rien pour recouvrir
la surface totale d'un rectangle il faut
avoir au préalable dessiner un rectangle
le problème vient donc de la phase de
design qui ne prend à aucun moment
compte du paramètre optimisation
matières premières en fait la découpe et
la fabrication sont souvent délocaliser
dans les pays en voie de développement
du coup et designers occidentaux ne sont
que très peu confronté à la gestion des
déchets générés par leurs propres
collections
l'industrie de la mode fonctionne donc
avec cette idée que l'optimisation de la
matière première est une problématique
secondaire et si plutôt que de continuer
à blâmer c'est unité de production
asiatique sur leur incapacité à gênés à
la gérer nos déchets on s'intéressait
pas un peu plus à nos méthodes de
contraception
vous savez ces fameuses règles rigides
de modélisme dont je vous ai parlé
est ce qu'elles sont si justifiée en
tentant de répondre à cette question
j'ai du coup je me suis je fais pas mal
de recherches sur le web et je suis
tombé sur ce projet de fin d'études du
designer john o'neill est à première vue
rien d'extraordinaire il porte une veste
de costard un trench et un pantalon
sauf que la grosse différence avec les
vêtements que vous pourriez
habituellement trouver dans le commerce
se trouve dans le patron lui-même
tous les éléments sont parfaitement
imbriquées tel un puzzle est le plus
intéressant dans tout ça c'est de voir
comment du haut-nil imagine ses
vêtements dès la toute première phase de
design
il étudie en fait l'impact que le
moindre détails stylistiques aura sur la
l'optimisation du tissu voilà voilà
comment en une fraction de seconde
remettre en cause dix ans de pratique
en fait j'étais fasciné et pourtant
énervé de comprendre que pendant toutes
ces années j'avais suivi une direction
sans jamais me poser de questions un
vrai mouton
alors petit à petit je découvre une
nouvelle philosophie de conception
souvent référencé sous le terme de 0,1
fashion design est en fait aux quatre
coins du globe une petite trentaine
quarantaine de designers développe des
vêtements dont le en fait de
l'optimisation la matière prévient
devient un critère essentiel pour le
design du vêtement est en fait ce qui
est drôle c'est qu'ils ont tous une
méthode et une approche différente et
pourtant un but commun celui de
continuer à créer des vêtements mais
sans produire de déchets et plus
incroyable dans tout ça c'est que ce
n'est pas une nouvelle fille une
nouvelle pratique autrefois les pièces
de tissus et de si précieuses qu'elles
étaient souvent considérés comme des
oeuvres d'art au point d'être transmises
de génération en génération
il était donc impensable de jeter quoi
que ce soit malheureusement aujourd'hui
le tissu né peut considérer dans le
tissage en tout cas n'est plus vraiment
considéré comme un artisanat de valeur
c'est juste considéré comme un simple
moyen matériaux de faire pour faire un
vêtement
ils peuvent intrigué par tout ce que je
venais de découvrir j'ai du coup moi
aussi décidé de faire commencer à faire
des patrons de vêtements zéro déchet est
par exemple ici c'est le résultat d'une
recherche que j'ai fait sur un pantalon
alors en haut vous avez le schéma du
patron tels que je l'aurais imaginé
avant de connaître le zéro déchet zéro
ici design alors toutes les zones noires
correspondent à des zones de déchets et
en l'occurrence on en a 10 7% puis en
dessous
vous avez le patron tel par le patron
repensé pour ne pas créer de déchets
alors vous allez me dire oui oui encore
des zones noires
oui mais en fait ces zones noires sont
tellement bien étudié elles me servent
aujourd'hui à faire des poches glissé
sur le dos du pantalon et pour l'avoir
testé je peux vous dire que c'est
le détail ces listings qui fait toute la
différence auprès des gens en tout cas
on peut donc dire que ces zones ne sont
plus des chutes mais sont bien une
valeur ajoutée aux vêtements en
parallèle de tout ça je me suis aussi
beaucoup intéressé le ciel de
prototypage 3d qui sont relativement
nouveau pour l'industrie textile et je
me suis dit waouh
mais là il ya un truc à faire pourquoi
on n'utiliserait pas le prototypage 3d
pour faire du zéro déchet parce qu'il
faut savoir que le prototypage de
manière générale et très
particulièrement le prototypage zéro
déchet c'est un processus itératif qui
implique forcément de faire des erreurs
donc il faut d'abord tout d'abord échoué
dans certaines directions pour ensuite
décider d'aller en explorer d'autres
et pour info au cas où vous l'auriez pas
remarqué la robe que vous voyez simuler
ici en 3d c'est la robe que je parte
aujourd'hui donc si à minima les
entreprises avaient recours les
designers avaient recours à ce type de
logiciels dans les entreprises la phase
de prototypage et de fabrication serait
beaucoup plus efficace et écologique
problème c'est qu'en france avec tout ce
patrimoine culturel qu on a autour de la
couture française
il est très très difficile de remettre
en cause des choses est de proposer de
nouvelles pratiques et de nouveaux
outils fin 2016
à force de pratiquer tout ça sur mon
temps personnel j'arrive à saturation
en fait mais que mes convictions
personnelles ne sont plus du tout en
phase avec mes activités
professionnelles
du coup je décide de quitter mon super
job dans l'industrie et je lance le
projet mille ans avant jc pour démontrer
aux entreprises et aux écoles de mode
qu'il est bel et bien possible notamment
grâce à la 3d de faire de la mode sans
générer de déchets sauf que vous savez
pour convaincre il faut apporter des
preuves tangibles
je décide alors de consacrer 5 mois de
mon temps au développement d'une
collection témoin et je partage en open
source
tous les patrons
cette collection sur le site web du
projet là c'est assez drôle parce que
j'ai eu pas mal de réactions du genre
wahou mais tu es folle pourquoi tu fais
ça tu peux pas tout partager
gratuitement tu vas te faire voler
l'idée tu devrais plutôt déposé un
brevet non non c'est juste pas le but en
fait le but de ce projet c'est de
sensibiliser par la démonstration
technique et le partage pour encourager
justement d'autres designers à aller
dans ce sens rappelez-vous que moi si
j'ai connu cette pratique c'est parce
qu'un designer anglais avait lui-même
partager toutes ces infos sur son site
web
donc s'il n'avait pas fait ça je ferai
pas ce que je fais aujourd'hui lorsque
la collection au sort son site web fin
2016 je rentre dans une phase un peu de
communication démarchage lors de
laquelle je communique sur les réseaux
sociaux
je vais à des salons a juré point des
appels à projets innovants
je propose aussi à des écoles de mode
d'organiser des workshops avec les
élèves
et puis je vois aussi d'en faire des
présentations dans les bureaux d'études
de marque alors globalement les échanges
sont à fait positif parce que les
entreprises ils voient un intérêt bond
économique avant tout mais je trouve que
ça a du sens que c'est novateur
sauf que bon les entretiens se conclut
en mode
bah ouais franchement le projet c'est
génial c'est sûr en fait c'est la vie
hein mais dans l'état actuel des choses
chez nous c'est pas possible parce qu'en
fait la remettrait en cause beaucoup
trop de choses mais peut-être qui sait
dans dix ans ça sera possible
alors là tu es contente parce que tu
t'es pas fait jeter mais c'est quand
même la douche froide
en fait il existe de plus en plus
d'initiatives à l'international sur ce
sujet visiblement en france est encore
trop avant gardiste du coup
je me dis c'est pas grave
les entreprises ne sont pas prêtes à
aller dans ce sens c'est pas grave
en fait je fais je vais faire changer
les choses par un autre biais
la communauté do it yourself en effet en
france et ailleurs dans le monde il
existe une grosse communauté de
personnes qui ont envie d'apprendre à
faire des choses par elle même et on les
appelle souvent les makers et c'est
makers sont souvent alerte sur les
valeurs éthiques et écologiques des
produits et du coup moi aujourd'hui je
prends le parti de créer des patrons à
destination du grand public et
j'organise également des workshops de
couture avec ces personnes dans
plusieurs villes en france pour
justement partagé ma pratique mes
astuces aimé technique quotidienne au
fil du temps j'espère initié une
communauté suffisamment importante
qu'elle encouragera naturellement les
marques à s'intéresser au sujet et à
aller dans cette direction
bref moi personnellement moi
personnellement je veux pas attendre
qu'on soit 10 milliards sur cette
planète et que les rois de la fast
fashion et dépouillé une ressource pour
me dire tu crois que j'aurais pu
faire un truc
[Applaudissements]